- All right, it's been a super fun,
sometimes frightening hour.
But let's close out
with some Halloween joy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
All right, so dressing up and
going door to door for candy
is a childhood rite of passage.
A Houston high schooler wants to make sure
that every kid gets that opportunity,
no matter their financial means.
So he created Y'allowen, which I love.
He distributes brand-new costumes
to kids in need in his community.
And we have him on the line right now,
along with his mama.
Say hi to BJ and Tracy
watching on Fox 26, everybody. (clapping)
(audience cheering and clapping)
What's up, y'all?
- Hi, Kelly.
- Oh my God, love.
This is the coolest thing ever
'cause, by the way, I
was one of those kids
that totally could've
used money for costume.
So how did this start?
- It started back three years ago
when we started the Pandemic.
We saw that there was a lot
of people who lost their jobs
and that kids weren't
able to get costumes.
So, I just love Halloween.
I cannot go without it.
And so we really wanted to spread that.
And so we became Y'allowen,
which is Halloween for all y'all.
- Aw, I love it.
(gasps) Mama, great job.
What a beautiful young man, your heart.
So, how many costumes do y'all do a year?
- So, since our first year in 2021,
we've distributed over 750 costumes.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- The way it works is we
have partner organizations
that support transitional housing
or domestic violence abuse victims.
And they give us a list of
the kids in their programs
with their gender and their age,
and if they wanna be a
princess or a superhero,
and then we match 'em up with costumes
that have been donated
or that BJ has raised money
to buy for his fundraising.
I am so incredibly proud of BJ.
My kids have never wanted for anything,
and he's helping these parents
that are having tough economic times
provide a little bit of normality
and some joy to these kids
on our favorite holiday, Halloween.
- Absolutely, it's escapism.
Every kid, you know, should get that joy
of like the theme of dressing
up whatever you want.
And being creative,
there's so much into it.
My kids love it, specifically my son.
Thank you so much, BJ,
for just having such a great heart,
and Tracy, thank you so much
for raising such a great young man.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
- Thank you so much, Kelly.
- Yeah.
And that's not all, guys.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
recognize that you're giving
kids in your community
the gift of a simple pleasure.
So they're giving you a thousand dollars
to get started on your efforts for
next year's costumes.
- Oh my God.
- Thank you so much.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Thank you guys so much!
Making Texas proud!
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Kyle Richards, Keith
Morrison, DC Young Fly,
Rick, Kate, and Simona.
Y'all have a great Halloween.
If it's not, try and change it.
(audience clapping)